a quarter of the people have no
confidence that we have free and fair
elections Andrew Sullivan was on
Andrew's a I would say a left leaning
author uh so this is a lefty this is a
Democrat uh but here he is making a good
point about how the more the Democrats
try to take out Trump the more they kind
of help him go by the issues I don't
know if people go by the issues I was
reading this today in the paper one in
three people in this country
will not accept the results oh one and3
will accept the results of the election
that's on both sides a quarter of the
people have no confidence that we have
free and fair elections Biden voters one
in three not confident of course 70% of
trump voters will only accept a trump
victory 46% of Biden voters will only
view his victory as legitimate why even
have an election I mean given numbers
like this you you really think it's
about
issues it's not it is why you have an
election the only way a country that's
divided can ever resolve its questions
is to have an election with the
candidates that both parties support
with no constraints and have us actually
decide who's going to be pres that's why
we do it that's what a democracy is
there's no way around that there's no
legal suit you got to get rid of that
and and the attempt to disqualify him
somehow on a technicality just smacks a
little more than a technical okay so I
am completely with Andrew S Sullivan on
that they continued obviously but the
the point he goes on a lefty show with
Bill Maher with a lefty audience in Los
Angeles and says guys you know if you
remove him from the ballot you do all
this stuff with the court cases you're
not letting the system you're not
letting the people make the decision
here and if you do that that's actually
like stick the knife and twisting it
into democracy right because then no one
is going to be like oh this system's
actually Fair like the Republican
certainly won't be and the Democrats
will kind of be like oh we know what we
did and and it's not
fair